(audience laughing)
- All right.
So very exciting.
We're here at Khan Academy with the team
and we have some students
from Khan Lab School as well
with the, I'd say legendary
Francis Ford Coppola,
most known for filmmaking.
Obviously The Godfather
movies, Apocalypse Now, Patton.
I think by the time you were in--
- The Outsiders.
- The Outsiders, yes.
You have more Academy
Awards than most of us,
(audience laughs)
but not just, I mean,
I think the one thing
that we're all gonna learn today is
as much as Francis is a legend
and knows so much and
is so steeped in film
that his interests go well beyond film.
Obviously wine now and other things.
Maybe a good place to
start since you are known
so much as a legendary filmmaker
is how did you get into that?
What was your arc from maybe being
the age of some of these
students at Khan Lab School,
you know, in your middle school
to eventually becoming a filmmaker?
- Well, for some reason my father,
who was a classical musician,
moved every eight months it seemed
and we were always in a new
house, in a new neighborhood,
and I was always the new kid at school
and my name was Francis, so they was,
"Oh, that's a girl's name."
So I got all of the typical
hazing when you're the new kid,
but I was very good at science.
I was very interested in
science and electricity
and I used to love to read
the lives of the inventors
and I felt I knew all about that,
so much to this extent that
when my father asked me
what I wanted to be when I grew up,
I said, "A nuclear physicist."
And he said to me, "Francis,
you can't flunk algebra
"three times in a row and
be a nuclear physicist."
And I said, "Why not?"
But nonetheless, I was discouraged
that I could ever be a scientist,
which is what I wanted to be,
because I was not good at math.
So whenever I went to a new school--
- But you were very strong at geometry.
- I was very, I won the geometry medal.
- [Interviewer] Yes, so it's that.
- I was really good at geometry,
but geometry you can see
and you can see the whole all the time.
Sometimes it's not
clear, but you see it all
and I was good at that.
So whenever I went to a new school,
I would always head to
the theater department
because they always needed people
who were good with
electricity and technology
and also that's where the girls were.
(audience laughs)
And I wanted to meet them.
So I figured if I was around
the theater department working,
I would get to meet the girls.
I could've also gone to the football team
where they had girls, but
I didn't qualify for that.
(audience laughs)
An interesting note to understand me
is that when I was nine years old,
I was paralyzed with polio,
which was a big epidemic in 1949
and it struck kids, many many
many children were paralyzed
until only a few years
later I think, 1951, '52,
they developed a vaccine
and the Sabin vaccine,
but my generation, polio was
the scary children's disease
and I got it and I missed the sixth grade
because I couldn't walk,
but through the wonderful
hospices of the March of Dimes,
it was a charity called
the March of Dimes.
Everyone donated dimes to
it and they sent a therapist
who slowly brought me back to the ability
to walk about a year and a half later.
- Wow, and so how did you go from
that state you're talking about
where you were a little bit
involved with drama and theater
to actually deciding that
you wanted to be a filmmaker
and actually making films?
- Well, I had an older
brother, five years older,
who was a very good
student and very handsome
and very accomplished and
wonderful to me by the way
and I just wanted to be like him.
In fact, he was already
interested in writing stories
and his name was August Floyd Coppola
and I just thought that was so
cool that I made my own name,
Francis Ford Coppola, just to imitate him.
(audience chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Ford, it
was not part of your name?
- Ford is my middle name, but I used it
because my brother had,
but I was born in Detroit
and my middle name was after Henry Ford
'cause my father, who
was a classical musician
played for the Detroit Symphony.
In those days, they
were the big orchestras
who were on the radio,
that was The Ford Hour.
- And so as your brother,
so how did that tie in too?
- Well, I just wanted to
be like him if I could.
You know, when you're five years apart,
there's no contest of you competing.
He can beat you up, he's smarter than you.
(audience chuckles)
But he was so kind to me
and encouraged me that I thought
that if he had, he was so good at school
that the family foot, he was gonna be
the first doctor in our
Italian American family.
So I thought I would be an eye doctor
so I could work with lenses and prisms
'cause I always loved prisms
and what light can do in a lab.
So later in college, he flipped
and became a philosophy major
and told my father he
was gonna be a novelist,
so then I said, "Well,
I'll be a playwright then."
(audience laughs)
So when I went, was ready in high school
to consider college, I thought I would try
to become a drama major and eventually,
I entered school as a playwrighting major,
but I of course worked in the
technical part of the theater,
doing the lighting and stuff.
One day when I was up on
a ladder hanging a light,
I saw the teacher, who
was always the director,
the shows were always
directed by faculty members,
and I saw the teacher telling the kids,
the actors, oh, you go here,
I thought I could do that.
So in college, I started to direct plays
and ultimately I was going to try to
be a writer and director in the theater
and in the theater in our country,
the great theater graduate school,
there are actually several great ones,
but one of the great ones
is the Yale Drama School,
which is a graduate school.
So I was gonna be, go right
to the Yale Drama School
and one afternoon, I was in
around the plaza of the college.
I pretty much just hung
around the drama department.
That was my life.
I noticed a little theater that said
today, 4:00 screening of
Sergei Eisenstein's film
Ten Days That Shook the World.
I'd never heard of Sergei Eisenstein
and it was a silent film,
but I had nothing to do
and I went in and there were about
maybe six other people in the theater.
No one was that interested
and it was truly silent
and it lasted almost four hours
and I had never seen a
film like that in my life,
that the editing itself made up
for the fact that there was no sound.
When they shot machine
guns, you could hear them
just by the way it was edited
because this Eisenstein,
who was a film director in the '20s,
invented and came up with new
ways of cutting film together,
which is spoken of in his era as montage.
The curious thing that
you could take a shot
and cut it next to another shot
and it means something different
than either of the shots
is a kind of magic alchemy
and I was just so impressed with that
that I said, "I'm not going
to the Yale Drama School.
"I wanna go to the UCLA Film School."
I changed my whole life and went on
to be a film student in America
at a time when no film student
had ever gotten to make a feature film.
- So that raises the question.
What was it about either the
mindset that you took to it
or how you developed
yourself or even just fortune
that put you in the right place
that allowed you to do that
which you just described?
A lot of students weren't
able to make a feature film.
- Well, in college in
the drama department,
I became very Machiavellian.
Do any of you know what that word means?
You all know that
Machiavelli was a minister.
He was actually on the outs
with the prince in Florence
and his name was Niccolo Machiavelli.
So he wrote a little book about,
a handbook for princes and
how to double cross people
and how to do all those,
what we now call Machiavellian things.
There was more to him than that,
but he's famous for that little book.
That little book you can
read in about two hours.
It's called The Prince
and it's all the rules of
doing all those political things.
I became very Machiavellian in college
(audience laughs)
because I wondered why
only the faculty members
got to direct all the
plays and no students.
So I did a little research
and I learned that
the plays were paid for by the fees
the students paid upfront for so-called
co-curricular activities
or extracurricular.
In other words, the
yearbook or the newspaper
or the drama department, those
were all considered clubs
and they were funded by student fees.
There were two clubs
when I went to college
at Hofstra College,
which is where the debate
that Mrs. Clinton and Mr. Trump had
two debates ago, was Hofstra College.
That theater that they
were in, I know backwards.
(Francis and audience laugh)
So what I did is I became the president
of both the musical comedy
club and the drama club,
which were very different kinds of kids,
but I became president of both
and I merged them together
and then having merged them together,
I made a rule that you
couldn't be in a show,
to act in a musical or a play,
unless you had not
missed the club meetings
or at least you couldn't
have missed three in a row
because no one ever went
to the club meetings.
(audience laughs)
Then but I did a good thing with it.
We had the meetings, but I also invited
everyone who wanted to to do
a little experimental workshop
or a little one act play,
so the meetings were good,
but during the meeting, I had
a vote and passed the rule
that faculty members
could not direct shows
that were funded by student money.
(audience laughs)
So suddenly all these drama
teachers who had come there
so they could direct the
big show couldn't direct it.
So I was the only student
who wanted to direct.
(audience laughs)
- Did you actually run for president
of two separate clubs
and enact those rules
with that in mind, that
I will get enough support
by forcing people to go to these meetings
and two clubs to allow
myself to direct the shows?
- Well, it's a funny thing about power.
(audience laughs)
You don't necessarily know
that you're amassing it,
but you sort of do.
(audience laughs)
But I was going in that direction
and it worked very well for me
because I got to do, not only
could I direct a production,
but I used the strength
of having the finance,
which was coming from the
club, we did ambitious shows.
We did original musicals.
We did a production of A
Streetcar Named Desire.
We did all these wonderful things
and many of the things were wonderful
that brought life to the drama
department because of it.
- How did you, so in college,
you get this great experience.
You're directing it sounds
like big productions.
How did that translate when you
first did your first movies?
You did the screenplay for Patton.
And you were quite young.
- Well, I went to the UCLA.
In those days, there were two
or three big film schools.
There was UCLA and USC and
in New York, there was NYU.
To make it more clear for you,
Marty Scorsese went to NYU.
George Lucas went to
USC and I went to UCLA.
(audience chuckles)
No one from any film school had
ever made a feature movie, ever.
So I sort of went to
UCLA with a big advantage
'cause I had been a theater student
and a theater student, one
of the fundamental things
a theater student has to learn
is about writing and acting.
Well, writing and acting
are the magical ingredients
of any theater or cinema or performance.
You could see a movie
and it could have beautiful photography
and it can have great art direction,
but if it has terrible
acting and a dumb script,
it's not gonna be successful.
Yet, a film that has a wonderful script
and wonderful acting that
has terrible photography
and terrible art direction and
everything else can be a hit.
So I always say that acting and writing
is the water, is the oxygen
and hydrogen that make water,
that if you focus on the
writing and the acting,
of course you want the
music and the photography,
everything to be beautiful,
but those are really where
the magic I think happens.
So having come from theater,
I knew a lot more about acting
than any of the cinema students,
who were much more into the camera.
The great film director
Orson Welles once said
that you can learn everything
about how to make movies in a weekend,
meaning the camera, the editing
and more or less, of course
that's a little overdoing it.
He, when he made his first
film, had a great photographer,
but nonetheless, it's somewhat true.
The camera and stuff is not the hard part.
The hard part is the
writing and the acting.
So having focused on that in theater,
I had an advantage when I
went into the film school
because there were philosophy students.
Terrence Malick was a philosophy student.
They were crazy to get
their hands on cameras
and I had already worked with actors
and also there's a sort of
prejudice against actors.
I don't know if you know what I'm saying,
but there's a sort of jock mentality
about actors among the film crews.
They think oh my god, they're such a,
you know, what do they do after?
Well, what an actor does is really hard
because if you play a violin,
not only do you have to be
able to play the violin,
you've got the violin
between you and audience.
The actor has to sort of
do what a violinist does,
except his instrument
is himself or herself.
So it's really terrifying to be an actor
and at the same time fight
the self-consciousness
that anyone would have.
So I always approached movies and theater
with tremendous respect for the actors.
The actors, actresses today
like to be known as actors
because it comes from the verb, to act.
It's the one who acts.
Not that you act a role,
which it indirectly means,
but it's the actor means
the principle person
making movement within the story.
It could be a man or a
woman, could be an actor.
Actress is sort of like
professoressa, you know?
Lady professor, it's diminutive.
So at any rate, I had this advantage of
having been a drama student
and also having been enough Machiavellian
that I could conspire,
which is what you have to do
to get a movie off the ground,
certainly in those days,
to try to conspire to
put together a movie,
which I did and I got to make.
Because I was the first student
to really make a feature film,
some other students from USA
heard about this weird guy,
notably George Lucas, who was about
four years, five years younger than me.
Four years younger than me.
So he kind of came around,
this skinny kid with a beard
when I was directing a
picture at Warner Brothers
and this kid is watching me.
Everyone on the show
is old and wore suits.
He was this skinny kid with a beard
and I looked at him looking at me
and I said, "Well, what do you see?"
And he said, "Not much."
(audience laughs)
With that, we became friends immediately.
We started hanging out together
and ultimately he became
sort of an assistant.
He wouldn't say that now,
(audience laughs)
but because he was younger
and I've known George Lucas
throughout all of his career.
Produced his first movies like THX 1138
and American Graffiti before he went
off on his own to do the
astonishing work that he did
and he's remained my friend.
He's one of the few directors who still
lives more or less in Northern California.
I think Solomon knows him.
(Interviewer laughs)
(audience laughs)
Did I answer your question?
- No, absolutely,
but just following up on George
as something you just told
me, which I found fascinating,
but the more I hear your
story, I'm connecting dots.
You aren't just known for writing
and directing these great films.
There's also a famous character
in popular fiction that
is based off of you.
- Yep.
That's Han Solo
(audience gasps and laughs)
because George felt
that I was, that I just
took crazy reckless chances
and would jump off a
mountain without knowing
what was down there to land on
and that I would end up with no money,
so he created, you can look it up.
Say Francis Coppola Han Solo
(audience laughs)
and you'll, you'll find that.
So I'm sort of a dashing failure.
(audience laughs)
- How do you, do you agree with that?
Do you see yourself in Han Solo?
- Well, I know what, you know,
George is what I used to call,
I always call an old stick in the mud
'cause George is very conservative,
although his imagination is
wild, but in his personal life,
he's pretty conservative
and I'm the opposite.
I'm much more, I'm not
afraid of taking chances
and taking risks because
so far what we know,
you get this one life and the worst thing
that could possibly happen when you're
this old, old, old man or old woman
to, say, be there, getting ready to die,
saying, "Oh, I wish I had done this.
"I wish I had done that."
That's, you don't wanna do that.
In my case, I'm gonna say,
"Oh, I got to make movies
"and I got to see my kids make movies
"and I got to make wine
"and I got to do experimental workshops."
I'm gonna be so busy talking about
all the things I got to do,
(audience chuckles)
that when I die, I'm not gonna notice it.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
And that's my recommendation.
(Interviewer laughs)
- So, and I think that
connects to another thing that,
and it's pretty obvious
when people hear you,
but above and beyond this,
I mean, learning itself
and I think this is a
connection between yourself
and what we try to do
here at Khan Academy.
At its core, learning is a bit of
a passion of yours, in and of itself.
- Well, it totally makes sense.
I mean, in life there are many
wonderful things you can do.
There are many pleasurable things.
Many of them unfortunately
have a bad side.
Drinking wine and alcohol in moderation
can be a wonderful thing, but
too much will make you sick
or anything you do that brings pleasure.
If you think girls are great
and you're running after girls,
then your wife is gonna,
(audience chuckles)
I've been married 53
years, so I know the value
of having one wife for a lifetime.
So you can't do that.
So if you eat too much, you'll
just get disgustingly fat,
which I have a problem with.
(audience chuckles)
But in life, learning
is as much a pleasure
as any of those things
and there's no bad part.
There's no, it doesn't bite you back.
You can't learn too much and overload.
Oh, I've over learned this
month, I just don't feel well.
(audience and Interviewer laugh)
The only thing I know like
learning like that is music,
in that I don't know any way,
unless maybe if you're listening
to eardrum-breaking rock and
roll where it could be bad,
but music is generally good for you
and we can talk about that
because there's a philosophy that believes
that music is the only way
that we can really understand
what's really out there,
beyond our senses.
Any rate, so learning, I always thought
when I was a little kid,
if they said to me, "You know, Francis,
"you're about to learn
about this and about that
"and you're gonna learn about algebra
"and algebra comes from the Arabs.
"It was called al jabr
"and they probably
learned it from the Greeks
"and it's really an
exciting way to solve."
No one ever told me at the
beginning of my education
what a lot of joyous fun it was.
It always had me scared that I was gonna
get that visit from Miss
Henchman to my father
and then I would get a, you know.
In those days, there was you got hit
if you got bad report cards, which I did,
but no one ever told me the
exciting side of learning
and not only that, I used to,
oh, how much school am I gonna?
You're never out of school.
I'm 77 and I learn so much.
Every night I'm learning.
Now I'm learning about genetics,
which is really fascinating,
about the human genome and
the chromosomes and the genes
and it's amazing to
know that the scientists
didn't even understand
it really until the '80s.
I mean, that's recent.
Some of you were probably,
well, not you guys,
but some of you were born
(audience laughs)
in the '80s and imagine,
they didn't even understand
how the gene worked (coughs)
and they don't entirely now.
Well, that's what I'm learning about now.
It's thrilling, it's so exciting.
Or to learn about history
and understand really,
we all know that the world is troubled
and that a lot of it focuses
on the Middle East and Islam,
but no one knows that
really you have to go back
almost to the first
World War to understand
the bad feelings that were
engendered at that time
and also that Islam is
not, Islam was the zenith
of intellectual study and
science in the 13th century,
in terms of, well, it's interesting
'cause in Islam, you have
to pray five times a day
and you have to point when
you pray towards Mecca.
So it was to their advantage
to really understand time
so they knew they would pray
at the right time each day.
So they studied the heavens
to be masters of time
and the reason that Islamic
science knew so much
about the heavens and
time was for that reason.
It's because they, and they wanted to
point in the right direction,
so they brought so much to us
in these areas of
astronomy and navigation.
Of course Islam, those states
were close to Ancient Greece,
so they preserved a lot of the knowledge
that had been in Greek and that's how
we still have such things as algebra.
- Yeah, and before we open it up
for some questions from the audience,
how did we get connected?
What was your connection,
how did you bump into Khan Academy?
- Well, I ran across the name
and that you had a course in algebra
and I said, "Why was I so stupid
"that I couldn't grasp algebra?"
So I looked at the
beginning algebra course
and I said, "Gee, if I had had this,
"I wouldn't have failed algebra
"three times and I understand."
No one ever explained it that there was,
that this was a method
for solving problems.
I always used to say, "Why
do I care what X means?
"I wanna know what something
that I know means."
(audience laughs)
But no one explained to me
that it was essentially a procedure,
an algorithm as you wish, to
learn how to solve a problem.
They didn't say that to me.
They just said, "You're in bad trouble.
"You're flunking algebra."
Since I wasn't at the
school from the beginning,
I was a new kid, I just
assumed I was stupid,
which is what they told me.
- Yep, so with that, let's
open it up for some questions.
- Hi, Mr. Coppola, I'm Karina.
I'm on the props team, so
you know we share that.
Thank you so much for coming.
This has been educational and hilarious
(audience laughs)
at the same time.
Outside of human genetics,
what learning do you feel like
you still have to accomplish
and what excites you now about film?
- Well, what excites me about film,
there are many fields that interest me.
I mean, history, philosophy.
Philosophy is the study of how to think.
I mean, what's better
than learning how to think
because you have to realize when
these early people occupied the Earth,
they didn't, no one was
there to teach them anything,
so they had to decide for themselves
and using the thought process
of, well, there's earth,
there's fire, there's water, there's air.
Maybe these are the basic elements.
They just were using their
ability to think to uncover,
so that's a wonderful
field, but in terms of film,
what's interesting to me about film
is that in the last 15 years,
film which used to be a photochemical,
in other words, we used
to have photographic film
that you'd put in a mechanical device
and would take a series of stills
and then you had to send it
to the lab and develop it.
In the last 15 years, all of
the elements of filmmaking
have changed from photo, mechanical
and mechanical to digital, electronic.
So the editing machine
really is a computer now
in which you compress the
images and put it in a computer
and then you can cut them
together as you wish.
The camera has become
so high in its quality
that a digital camera is
sufficient to take the picture,
which only 35 millimeter
film used to be able to take
and the projector in
the theaters you go to
when you go to the movie theaters,
they're not loading up cans of film.
They're also digital and there's possible
to connect to them through satellite.
So in the last 15 years,
everything about filmmaking
or cinema has changed totally
to a different technology
and my feeling is that
how could that happen
without to some degree it changed
the essence of what a movie is?
Because now it's being
made so totally differently
that perhaps there are new horizons
that wouldn't have been
possible in the old days
when it was really a piece
of photographic film.
New things that we can do
that we couldn't do before
and that's sort of personally what I'm,
I'm experimenting with
something I call live cinema.
What is live cinema?
Live cinema means it's,
in my case, a story
told like a movie, looks like a movie,
except the actors are actually
doing it live in that moment.
Now we all know that
they do live television,
like some of you probably saw
Peter Pan or The Sound of Music,
but whenever you see a
live show on television
or a soap opera or something,
it looks like television.
It doesn't behave like a movie.
Yet, when we see a movie on television,
we know it's a movie.
Even though it's coming on the same way,
it looks like a movie.
The way the story is told is different.
The shots are telling the
action in a different way,
so what I'm interested in is
learning how it to be cinema still,
that it looks and behaves like a movie.
You wouldn't know that
it's even not a movie,
except the actors are doing
it live in that moment.
Then to do that, I did
two workshops recently,
one at UCLA and one in
Oklahoma Community College
where the school invited me
to work with their students
and let me do my idea there,
as an experimental workshop,
what we call a proof of concept,
to see if you could do it.
I learned so much that
I wrote a little book
that I'm just finishing called
Live Cinema and Its Techniques
and it's my hope personally
that I would get the opportunity
before I do the final,
oh, I got to do this,
I got to do that, to get to do
some live cinema as
something I've written.
I wanna remind you all that I used to be
a drama counselor in a camp when I was 17,
so I used to just, all summer,
first week I'd do plays
with the six-year-olds,
then I'd do plays with the
seven and eight-year-olds,
then the nine and 10-year-olds,
and then finally at the end of the summer,
we'd bring the boys at
15 and the girls at 15
from the nearby girls
camp and do a musical.
Boy, was that an experience.
(audience laughs)
- Hi, Mr. Coppola, my name is Jia.
I work on the sustainability
team here at Khan Academy.
It's such an honor to have you here.
I'm a huge fan of your films.
I also love the films of
your daughter, Sofia Coppola.
I wanted to ask what kind
of advice did you give her
when she was starting out her film career
and also how did you balance your role
both as her father and as co-producer
of some of her own films?
Thank you.
- Well, Sofia was always a
very precocious little kid.
She was, even at age
six and seven, she was.
I remember I once took her when she was,
I mean, five or four, we all had to make,
on Godfather II, we had to
go to Dominican Republic
and we flew in this plane
and we got off in Miami
and it was really hot and humid
and I said to her, "Sofia,
how do you like Miami?"
She said, "It's not my
ami, it's your ami."
(audience laughs)
So I knew I was in for a ride with Sofia,
but it's interesting, she came to me
when she was around 21, 22
and she said, "Dad, I'm
interested in fashion
"and I'm interested in
fashion photography."
And she'd done some modeling
and designing clothes.
"And I'm interested in writing stories,
"but I really want to
be a painter and paint.
"Am I just a dilettante?"
I said to her, "You know,
parents always make the mistake
"of wanting their kids
to focus in on something.
"I'm telling you the opposite.
"Don't focus.
"Do everything you love
because if you learn
"about everything you love, one day,
"what you're meant to do in your life
"will just come together for you
"and it will be something that
"makes use of all the different things.
"Someday you'll find what you wanna do
"and it will involve stories
"and it will involve fashion
and all those things."
And it turned out that a few years later,
she made her short film at her high school
and I could see that
she had a lot of talent.
So I do think that parents often because,
you know, we in the past, there
was a terrible depression,
way before, in the '30s,
but people were
traumatized that their kids
needed to study something
they could make a living with
and the best way to do
that is just don't special,
I think that people may disagree,
but don't specialize too young
because being interested in one thing
might stop you from thinking
you could be interested in another thing.
Be interested in everything you can be.
Everything you love,
you should learn about
because then one day, it
will all come together
and be useful for whatever it is
you choose you wanna do with your life.
That was the case with Sofia.
- Hello, I'm Sam from
KLS and I was wondering
if you could travel back
in time to middle school,
would you do anything differently?
- What's middle school,
what grade is middle school?
- [Sam] Sixth through eighth.
- Well, sixth grade I was paralyzed
in bed watching television.
(audience laughs)
Watching television day and night
and that was before the remote
control, so I was stuck.
I couldn't walk to change it.
(audience laughs)
I was a prisoner of mid '50s television,
but you know,
(audience laughs)
my school, I went to 22 schools
before I went to college,
so I was always, I felt like an outsider.
I had no friends at all.
You don't have time to make friends
when you're there for six
months and I always did badly,
so I was always in trouble with my father.
I wish that I had the sense to say,
when he was coming at me,
seeing my report card,
with his belt folded in his
hand, I wish I had said,
"But you take me out of
school every six months,
"so how can I possibly get good marks?"
So I was a sad lonely
kid through middle school
and wanted to have friends
and kept moving to different places
and when you move as far away
as from New York to California,
it's really different.
In those days, L.A, Los Angeles
was so different from New York.
They didn't have baseball.
They didn't have comic book stores.
They didn't have White Castle hamburgers.
(audience laughs)
So I was just miserable at
your age, I hate to say,
but Hemingway, Ernest
Hemingway, the writer,
the famous American writer, said that
if you wanna be a writer,
you should have an unhappy childhood.
So I had an unhappy childhood.
(audience laughs)
- Hi, I'm Angelie from Khan Lab School
and I was just wondering
what were some struggles
that you had directing your first movie?
- Well, my real first movie
was a little horror film
that I made in Ireland when I was about,
I mean, a feature film,
when I was about 21
and you know, I guess what struck me was
I always have been a person with
a lot of good ideas or good imagination
and I would always see all these things,
but when you make a film,
you have to take what's in your mind
and what is your imagination
and you have to find
practical ways to do it
and it's not always as easy as you think,
that it's kind of what they
say in car terminology,
when the rubber meets the road.
In other words, the world
of imagination and fantasy
is wonderful because you have no limits.
It's just as, you can just
cook something up in your mind,
but then to translate that into a form
that other people can see and enjoy
involves a lot of practical stuff,
of scheduling and budget and
the shot you had in mind,
you can't really fit it in.
It's not like you thought.
So you have to learn as part
of the creative process,
to learn to be inventive and flexible,
to try to, there's two roads.
There's what you imagined
and to what you can do
and you have to be the one between those
and use whatever cleverness
you can to get there.
So when I made my first
film, I realized that
the practical side was
really very important
or you wouldn't get the
great ideas in the film.
- So just to close out
and I think all of us
would love to sit here all day
and continue to, or all the whole week,
(audience chuckles)
but just to finish off,
there's some parallels
between what we're doing
and things that you're interested in
and that you have experience in,
especially as, you know,
you just talked about film,
going into a new era with the technology.
Obviously, we're trying to do things
along those lines in education,
trying to reach a lot of folks.
What advice in any form would
you have to everyone here,
both the students and the
members of Khan Academy
as we go off on our journey?
- Well, all human beings
and all animals really
seem to be good at play, we like to play.
It's a natural thing we do
and we have to realize
that work that we do
later in life is really
a development of that.
So I try to keep the work I
do as much like play as I can.
I can make a quick demonstration,
if you want a quick--
- Absolutely.
- Could I have, where can I get
about this group of kids in a circle?
Where is there room to do that?
- All right, y'all wanna
get in a circle here?
- Go over there where we can see you.
- Okay.
(audience chuckles)
- This is an acting exercise.
- All right, good.
(audience chattering)
- So in the center,
no, no, not that many.
Just the ones over there.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, how many you want?
- Well, everyone sitting down here.
Go make a circle over there.
I would do it with everyone,
but I don't see a space.
Now make a circle, all hold
your hands in a circle.
(audience chuckles)
Okay, good.
Now make the circle as wide as you can.
Come out to me right now.
Is that about it?
Little more.
Okay.
Now this is an acting exercise.
Actors have to be very concentrated
because they have to appear,
when someone says something to them,
they have to make it seem as though
they're seeing it for the first time,
like if you say something in a play,
it's in the script, so you
know you're gonna say it,
but how do you do, so we play a game.
When I work with actors,
I try to make it as much fun as I can.
This game is called Sound Ball
and the way it's played,
if I go like this,
- [Interviewer] All right.
- I have an imaginary ball, right?
Boom boom boom.
I'm gonna throw it to you.
You catch it.
Now, here's the, now throw it back to me.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna throw it to you,
but I'm gonna make a
sound when I throw it.
You ready?
Bop.
Now when you catch it,
you catch it with bop.
- Bop.
- [Francis] And then you throw it to me,
you give it your own sound you want to.
- [Girl In Orange] Boop.
- Boop, okay.
(audience chuckles)
So when you catch it, you catch it
with the sound the person threw it to you
and this is to teach actors concentration
'cause they don't know when a line
is gonna come to them, all right?
So here we go.
Can you do it?
Throw the ball to him.
Throw the ball to anyone you want.
Make a sound.
- Zap.
- [Francis] Catch it with the sound.
- [Francis] And throw
it with another sound.
- Um, zoom.
- [Girl In Orange] Zoom.
Woosh.
- Woosh.
Zing.
- Zing.
- Make it louder.
- [Boy In White] Plop.
- Plop.
Sound.
(everyone laughs)
- [Francis] You gotta
do it a little faster.
Go ahead.
- Preedooldoo.
Dang.
- [Boy In White] Dang.
Um.
- Um.
Zing.
- Can you do it faster?
- Zing.
(blows raspberry)
(audience chuckles)
- [Girl In Orange] Zip.
- Zip.
Boom.
- Boom.
Ding.
- Ding.
(squelches)
- Now don't make it hard.
Make the sounds clear so they can do it.
Now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do the same thing.
We'll go a little faster
and I'm gonna throw a second ball in.
(audience groans and laughs)
Really hard, ready?
I'll start it, ready?
Bop.
- Bop.
Bing.
- Bing.
Zip.
- Boop.
- [Boy In White] Boop, boop.
Ball noise.
- Ball noise.
- Something.
- Boom.
(laughs)
- [Francis] We'll do it once
more, but you get the idea.
You have to be aware if you're an actor.
You have to be aware and
not look like you're aware,
but if someone's gonna throw you the ball,
you wanna be there to catch it.
You ready, I'm gonna do it again.
- Bop.
- Bop, zing.
- [Boy In White] Zing.
Zoop.
- [Francis] Zoop.
- Ding.
Bop.
- Bop.
Zip.
- Zip.
Bing.
- Bing, boop.
- [Boy In White] Boop, zop.
- [Francis] Wop.
- [Boy With Blonde Bangs] Zop, wop.
(audience laughs)
- You get the idea.
(audience applauds)
Thank you very much.
But there are 1,000,000 acting games
they call theater games that we could play
and whenever possible, if you can work
and develop something
that you wanna develop,
like in this case, concentration,
it's better to do it
through the form of play
because then the day becomes fun.
So I try to make all the work,
especially creative work
'cause that's so much fun as you know,
as much play as possible.
- Awesome, well, thank
you, thank you so much.
I think this is gonna be a huge treat.
This was a treat for us and
I think everyone watching
on Facebook and online, so thank you.
- Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
(audience applauds and cheers)